4 novembre 2008 Sylvie oberlusconi ne va
pas fêter la victoire de Barack Obama il
passe la nuit avec vous
Patrick chia delario bonsoir vous êtes
ici parce que vous avez couché avec
Sylvio Berlusconi et ça je crois qu'on
peut l'applaudir bravo
pas évident
comment ça va bellissime
et merci pour m'avoir invité ce soir
merci ça donne envie de faire de la
politique
[Musique]
Patrick sia rebonsoir en septembre 2008
l'homme d'affaires Diane Paolo Tarantini
qui souhaite s'attirer les bonnes grâces
de Silvio Berlusconi vous invite à une
soirée au palais latioli il vous dit de
vous habiller légèrement plutôt en noir
et de pas trop vous maquiller est-ce
qu'il était question d'argent oui
[Musique]
pour la soirée mais simplement pour un
dîner il n'y avait pas de d'accord pour
faire du sexe ou pour aller pour coucher
avec le président donc j'avais convenu
2000 euros avec Jean Paulo Tarantini
alors quand vous arrivez au palais
gratuit vous découvrez une vingtaine de
femmes deux hommes et le petit chien
froufrou qui est le petit chien que
Laura bouche a offert à Sylvie
oberlusconi et très peu maquillée aussi
alors la soirée commence Berlusconi
d'abord il montre un documentaire où on
le voit avec les grandes ce monde à la
Maison Blanche au G8 et ensuite tout le
monde chante une chanson qui s'appelle
que ferions-nous sans toi Sylvio
était chanté en même temps tout le monde
dansait moi j'étais la seule qui n'est
dans ses pas
et le président est une personne très
joyeuse il raconte des blagues
il était très affectueux avec nous
toutes
il passait dans l'autre salle et
l'arrivée avec des petits paquets il
sait très bien recevoir donc dans ces
petits paquets il y avait des bracelets
des colliers
tout il y avait des papillons tout était
en forme de papillon c'était comme
comme une compétition presque entre les
filles pour recevoir ces paquets
alors on boit du champagne et un moment
au milieu du dîner vous sentez une main
baladeuse un petit peu comme ça vous
regardez autour de vous dans un coin il
y a deux filles qui s'embrassent donc ça
commence à prendre un tour un peu tous
faut bien le dire
et au milieu du repas Silvio Berlusconi
vous invite à danser un slow très
sensuel coller vraiment collé comme ça
c'était un slow vous savez très bien
comment les danses
je sais comment on fait
alors ce qui a beaucoup séduit Silvio
Berlusconi c'est que vous ne le
courtisez pas vous ne le draguez pas il
y a une fille de Marie qui ne croit plus
en les hommes parce qu'il devait savoir
déjà quelque chose sur moi et il a dit
je vais aller la prendre avec mon jet
privé pour lui faire comprendre que les
hommes ne sont pas tous pareils et alors
là je m'étais un peu fâchée parce que
j'ai dit mais tu parles de moi devant
tout le monde il m'a répondu oui moi je
sais tout de toi
ce qui m'a émerveillé
là il vous demande de rester chez lui au
palais gratte-ciolis cette nuit là et
vous vous dites c'était pas prévu au
contrat alors à ce moment-là il y a jam
Paolo Tarantini qui vous dit si tu
refuses de rester tu n'auras pas 2000
euros tu n'auras que 1000 euros donc ce
soir là vous ne restez pas vous
retournez au palais grati le 4 novembre
2008 vous y allez avec deux amis dont
une Barbara n'a que 23 ans et là Sylvie
Auchan Sylvio chante deux chansons une
qui s'appelle la première fois et une
qui s'appelle la dernière fois
qui avait été toujours écrit par lui
c'est un poète voilà alors à 23h ce soir
là
les parts vous laissant seul vous avec
Silvio Berlusconi et là effectivement
vous devez l'attendre dans le grand lit
à baldaquin qui lui a été offert par
Vladimir Poutine
nous y sommes ces gens va m'attendre
dans le lit de Poutine quand même alors
là vous mettez en marche votre petit
magnétophone alors vous dites j'ai
toujours un petit magnétophone dans ces
cas-là parce que j'ai été victime d'un
homme violent et donc maintenant je me
protège j'ai besoin d'un petit
magnétophone donc cette nuit du 4
novembre 2008 Sylvie oberlusconi ne va
pas fêter la victoire de Barack Obama il
passe la nuit avec vous voilà et le
lendemain matin vous êtes ravis enfin en
tous les cas c'est ce que vous lui dites
est-ce que c'est vrai
si je dois être sincère il a été très
affectueux avec moi même l'appel qu'il a
passé le lendemain quand je suis partie
de Palazzo gratzoli il m'a appelé
plusieurs fois
avec lui donc en fait le lendemain matin
donc vous dites s'il veut Berlusconi
qu'il a été un bon amant
pas d'après ce qu'on sait par les
enregistrements il a été très affectueux
oui
c'est plus beau non de laisser un peu de
mystère c'est très très bien passé donc
avec balusconi vous lui dites un jeune
aurait joui en une seconde toi ça a duré
très longtemps et quand vous lui dites
qu'il y a longtemps que vous n'avez pas
fait l'amour aussi bien avec un homme
vous avez un peu des problèmes etc il
vous dit tu devrais te caresser plus
souvent donc en plus il prend il est
très affectueux il prend soin de vous
savez écoutez à plusieurs reprises les
enregistrements
alors donc il vous propose de figurer
sur la liste des élections européennes
alors député européen en Italie c'est
bien payé c'est 20000 euros par mois
donc il lui dit ouais si tu veux être
député européen j'ai pas de problème
et là à ce moment là pas de chance
madame Berlusconi demande le divorce en
accusant son mari de fréquenter des
mineurs alors à ce moment là on vous dit
bon ben les européennes ça va être un
peu la prochaine fois tu vas te
contenter des municipales à Bari dans
les Pouilles l'endroit dont vous êtes
originaire vous vous retrouvez dans les
Pouilles avec très peu de voix pas
vraiment élus et là vous parlez des
enregistrements que vous avez réalisé au
palais gratuit avec votre copine Barbara
et comme par hasard votre appartement
est cambriolé
on vous vole votre PC en vous volent des
CD des agendas des photos des photos
avec Silvio et on vous vole aussi alors
ça c'est plus bizarre des petites
culottes
plat qui est resté oui il est encore là
et maintenant l'appartement est vide
heureusement les enregistrements étaient
en sécurité voilà
donc tout a été volé et peut-être ces
gens là chercher exactement ces
enregistrements et ils ont pas trouvé et
puis le lendemain le juge m'a appelé ma
convoqué et à ce moment-là j'ai pensé je
vais dire la vérité là et en disant la
vérité voilà je suis là aujourd'hui
alors quand le scandale a éclaté c'est
un scandale planétaire c'est une
histoire extraordinaire comment a réagi
votre maman
ma mère est en train de vivre une
période vraiment terrible moi je n'ai
pas peur
si je n'avais pas ma famille je ferai
même pire et encore maintenant il y a
des gens qui m'arrêtent dans la rue et
qui me disent courage continue vas-y
parce que tu as parlé alors que les
autres se taisent
la vie a changé
je n'ai plus de possibilité de
travailler c'est difficile parce que en
Italie ils ont peur ils ont peur donc
disons que maintenant je suis presque
une nomade je suis désolé pour toi mais
tu t'es tu t'es vu plongé dans un conte
de fée et tu t'es saoulé de belles
paroles et tu te réveilles avec la
gueule de bois et c'est malheureux pour
toi mais c'est vrai que c'est ce monde
du pouvoir moi je
m'en méfie et parce que je sais que
c'est un monde où on se fait briser on
se fait manipuler on se fait utiliser et
puis on se fait jeter quoi c'est un
monde qui est sans pitié on n'a pas les
épaules merci en tous les cas merci
beaucoup moi je suis très content
parce que ma femme m'a autorisé à voir
une escort-girl et c'est la première
fois
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu